all right married in nigeria and i ain't
legit here
you have a good life oh she might regret
that one later anything legit here
you have a good life angela comes back
on set after storming off and says her
marriage to michael isn't legit in
america she also made a 90-day tele-all
history i think this was the first time
someone walked off twice i can't wait to
talk to you about how the rest of the
cast reacted to her behavior
if you were a 90 day cast member would
you stand up to angela
be honest let me know why or why not in
the comments
you haven't had your period in how long
ah two months plus it sounds like yara
might be pregnant again and if she is
she says she's moving back to ukraine
well i would really just fly back to
ukraine i would just go to my mama's
side
also oswello and kalani faces mom and
sister for the first time since their
big altercation you guys don't really
disrespect
mom told me go find another wife oh do
you think oswello should forgive his mom
or is he better off without her
i don't know
let's talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia
angela has been on fire and this little
hot red jumpsuit
these brand new puppies
after she flashed everyone and walked
off set during a heated argument with
michael and his aunt i can't help but i
went so far everybody sees my now
she decided to return to her seat and
apologize but before we get into that
quick question do y'all remember why
angela got so mad in the first place
because i didn't hi sean sorry again
are you feeling better no i don't feel
good now i feel hot you know
when she returned no one brought up the
fact that she overreacted and flashed
her boobs twice
[Music]
they were acting like it didn't happen
feel bad i apologize lydia for doing
that but you go too far man
look at lydia's face so i apologize for
being vulgar
for how i acted but not what i said
okay to refresh your memory angela's
outburst during part one of the tell-all
started after michael attempted to get
her to be quiet so his aunt could say
why she thinks he still needs to have a
baby
although angela can't give him one
michael i'm very upset with you more
nate lydia you should have told aunt
lydia respect you hush my wife huss you
never do that with aunt lydia i told him
my native language
oh calm down next angela made an attempt
to put a wedge between michael and aunt
lydia did he also tell you ain't lydia
one of your first friend requested me on
facebook come out of your nephew's mouth
that don't get too closer i said why i
like ain't lydia well brenda but don't
get too closer did you not say that okay
we are in the court of law did you not
say that no you are lost
i didn't you know
skyla is like mama please you're a liar
man i wonder who's lying for real
i can't tell either way right after that
angela sort of broke up with michael she
didn't call it a breakup because as we
know breakups with them don't count they
like to break up and get right back
together but she did say a few things
one in particular that
i hope she doesn't regret listen i don't
want to divorce i just do what i want to
do i am married to nigeria and it ain't
legit here
you have a good life you got to hell you
son of a [ __ ]
all right we're done for what
scholar when i walk out this door i'm
going to the hotel
for what
scholar we're out here
love
michael is obviously at a loss for words
love but i have a few things to say
one angela admitting that her marriage
isn't legit in america in my mind just
takes away all the credibility she's
basically saying it's not real at least
while she's not in nigeria all of what
she was saying to on lydia you better
respect me woman okay that's my husband
my husband goes right out the door
second thing
i know a number of you think skyla
should be embarrassed and while i know
exactly where you're coming from think
about it she was raised by this woman
i'm sure she's seen a lot worse what the
[ __ ] tracy say
i don't know now lastly i couldn't help
but notice that during both of angela's
explosions on part one of the tell-all
and part two the cast
had nothing to say
usually they chime in and speak up when
someone's in the wrong and angela was
clearly in the wrong
talk
they did it to natalie you like two-face
jovi like what is it the strip club like
seriously and they did it to a swellow
you not allowed to push your mama his
mom
there has to be mutual respect that
makes no sense and his sister tammy you
were the aggressor you jumped out of
that you jumped out of the seat first
but when it comes to angela oh they were
quiet they didn't say a thing
well
until she walked off set she's extra
like it's crazy
and even then some people were making
excuses for her actions i think she
didn't feel good
it's a lot of drama for her and she's
just got that surgery so
goodness okay so this brings us back to
the question i asked you earlier
if you were a 90-day cast member at the
tell-all would you call angela out for
her behavior or would you just let
angela be angela so i think she just got
pissed off okay
so i have to think about my answer
because i didn't want to sound like a
punk
i ain't scared of you mother
honestly
i'm not a confrontational person i know
people say that all the time but i'm
really not i don't like drama
obviously i like watching it but
i don't want to have it so if i was in
their shoes
i probably would keep my mouth closed
too because you don't want to
have any confrontation with angela see
michael knows i value my peace okay
but you know what i would do is reach
out to her afterwards when she's calm
much calmer
and suggest some ways that she can go
about expressing herself there you go
that's what i would do that's my
politically correct but honest answer
oh [ __ ] you didn't check out for me now
you want to call me
kiss my ass i'm going out i'm in my
little hot outfit i'm going out and i'm
going to get some attention and i'm
going to get some good attention
all right you calm down [ __ ] say
goodbye see now you see them now you
i've done everything i can to keep this
relationship together what have you done
for me lately
it's not a damn thing but keep me
miserable
honestly i'm not gonna let michael take
away my dignity
i ain't gonna call it a breakup i ain't
caught nothing i'm gonna call it i'm
gonna do what i wanna do he's been doing
what he wants to do
visa comes in we'll talk about it then
until then i'm gonna live my life good
night angela left a tell-all for good
which
kind of sucked because i would have
loved to hear what she had to say about
these next two couples you haven't had
your period in
how long
ah two once let's move on to yara who
thinks she might be pregnant but she
doesn't want to take a pregnancy test do
you want to be pregnant look at jovi
shaking his head they will show me
pretty good the more they see that girl
you might as well get it over with i
think if i would have a second child i
would really just fly back to ukraine i
would just go to my mama's side
that's it yara went on to say that if
she is pregnant she is moving back to
ukraine with no hesitation because with
jovi's work schedule he's never home i'd
not say i would do worse for joey but i
would just make him to travel after me
all the time germany are you willing to
let her go just like that without
even trying to fight i mean it's your
kid going away your kids well it's a
little bit different with my situation
because when i get off of work i can
always just go to ukraine so
was that shade
speaking of shade there was a moment
when yara started going at it with
asuelu sister tammy if you don't have
respect for your mom don't i do but my
mom i respect my husband you know my mom
will not tell me go back to childhood
from another hospital don't talk to me
yes i don't know i also don't have such
a great sister like you oh y'all with
the glad bag she's been so sweet lately
i forgot that she has a mouth on her
don't make me come to you though
oh honey honey please all right let's
round things out on if asuelu should
forgive his mother after she told him to
go find another wife i gave you my
answer and i don't want to keep being
pressured into having a baby son you
better find another one please we'll
leave for giving tammy for another day
first of all when shawn announced that
asuelu's mom and sister were at the
tell-all we have his mom
and his sister tammy in the studio today
it was like he and kalani didn't even
know they would be there kalani started
crying immediately kalani this is the
first time you're seeing
lucina and tam since christmas
what's going through your mind
anger
what would you like to say to them
what what would i say what is there to
say
the attitude
okay well there are definitely some hard
feelings here yeah kalani and asuelu
were obviously still very hurt
she's my mom and i love her very much
so it's just
break my heart that
she come in my family for holidays and
that's the last time i spoke to her oh
you can tell that this really bothers
him
it's sad to watch he's so weak he's a
baby
and he knew i love him so much his mom
was open to making up but she wanted him
to apologize first for disrespecting her
by kicking her out of kalani's parents
house
does your mom
feel that
asuelu is choosing
kalani
over you guys
oh yeah totally totally you can tell i'm
not you can tell why wouldn't he choose
us at this point look at how you act
sammy can i talk
chuck i'm choosing what is right you
guys don't really disrespect
mom told me go find another wife how can
you repair the relationship with your
mom
to be honest
it takes me a time to think about it
it's i'm not she's my mom think about it
you'll win still win
oh tammy don't you see why i saved her
for another day
anyway what do you think should i
swallow apologize should he forgive his
mom for what she said well here's my
take
why can't they both say sorry
isn't that an option
they both were in the wrong
asuela was wrong for telling his mom he
wanted another baby when kalani already
said no
and he was wrong for pulling out that
baby blanket we're trying to help you
and his mom has been wrong
for so many things so in my opinion
i feel like they both should just
apologize life is too short
but that doesn't mean you can't keep
your distance hold on let me be clear on
that okay
just because you forgive someone doesn't
mean you have to be close
do i need to say that again for people
in the back after tonight our
relationship will not
continue
no more all right 90 day fans fam
nothing got solved at the end of their
conversation but i can't wait to keep
the conversation going with you and read
your thoughts i'll see you next week
when the other way season 3 premieres
but until then make sure you stick with
et because we are covering it all i will
see you next time